[Music]
in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning we take you to
the famed Venice neighborhood of Los
Angeles it's a place where skateboards
are common but women on skateboards well
not so much Jamie yuccas went for a ride
to introduce us to a skate group that
took the idea of girl power on wheels it
may not look like it but these women are
on their way to a board meeting and yes
that pun is intentional
they call themselves girls world and
their mission is simple change the way
the sport of skateboarding sees women
dude can we do kippis parking lot again
that and vice versa I met with a
photographer this morning it all started
about a year ago on the bike paths and
side alleys of Venice California the
mecca of male-dominated skateboard
culture I was on the Venice Boardwalk
and as a woman without a skateboard it
is a very intense place you have just a
lot of cat calls and just it's not very
comfortable so tight growing up Lucy
Osinski always felt empowered when she
wrote a skateboard but she also felt
alone I was addicted to it but I just
didn't feel supported in the same way
that I wish I was so I started skating
with another girl
that one other girl turned into three
other girls including julia gadget sama
those three other girls need four other
girls in long story short they said hey
how fun would it be if we got everybody
together to skate at once they ended up
with nine women in the group and they
knew they needed a name I felt like we
were all like an ice-cream swirl like
there was different colors and ages and
types of people and we were just
swirling together and I was I just said
girl swirl Nieto's at first they stayed
in touch informally with text messages
good but Mariah Marquez says they
quickly outgrew that we went to
Instagram and that just kind of exploded
overnight with other girls being stoked
on it it's not just like a few other
girls stoked on it though there's almost
50,000 Instagram but it's not just
online twice a month
gross swirl hosts a group skate in
Venice where dozens of women show up
many for their very first time on wheels
we never actually know how many girls
are going to show up to each group skate
you feel safe as a woman and for us to
have created that space is I think like
I don't know that's what I love the most
most of these girls are in the Venice
area the fact that we were all within
like a couple mile radius and didn't
know about each other and now we've just
like come together it's just I mean it's
amazing the group attracts all ages from
grown women to the youngest
five-year-old Kenny Pollard how fast do
you think you can go on the skateboard
pretty fast if penny could do it your
shoulders and your eyes are your
steering wheel there's no way I could
resist you don't have to like riff you
don't have to do tricks we're just
asking to kick bush we're there to like
support you the whole idea is we're
trying to make this less intimidating
for women when you're a woman alone on
this skateboard it's very different when
you're a woman together with all these
other people you really create Girl
Power Girl Power is real you can change
things in your communities
that community is now global the group
has gotten messages from women as far
away as Italy and Dubai all wanting to
start chapters of their own and now
girls world even has the ultimate symbol
of skater cred
a board of its own built by iconic
skateboard brand Carver only pro
athletes get their own skateboard so if
the fact that our group is getting to
launch one with them is amazing it's
beautiful it is beautiful but not nearly
as beautiful as a sunset skate along the
Venice Boardwalk possible only because
of nine women determined to get everyone
else on board for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles board was
beautiful absolutely beautiful good for
them you know how to do that no I mean I
in high school I did with skateboarder a
couple times do you join I look at Jamie
I'm thinking it she looks a little like
Nana which is what I would look to on
the skateboard but I admire her for
doing it like Nana that would be me that
would be that's not a knock on Jamie
because that would so be me I admire for
getting up and doing yeah when I was a
kid had a huge massive epic wipeout that
cured me of it for a while and then when
my kids got back into it I tried and you
break that was enough I didn't break
anything I just it was there were a lot
of it was it's really buried deep Thank
You Jamie you good